a lot has changed this year we've got a
worldwide pandemic
we're all stuck working from home so why
not make the most out of your time at
home
that's why today we're talking about the
top five technologies you should learn
in 2021
so let's get started with number five we
have augmented
virtuality and extended reality in 2021
we can expect these forms of
technologies being further integrated
into our lives
usually working in tandem with some of
the other technologies we've mentioned
in the list ar
and vr is expected to play a huge role
in the field of healthcare
by providing training simulations to
help medical professionals and for
opticians to perform
eye tests it is also to play a huge role
in the educational sector
greatly improving the interactivity the
vr video and gaming market is expected
to grow to 2.9 and 2 billion
in 2021 respectively snap microsoft
atnt and nexus studios are some of the
major companies working towards ar
and vr you need skills like software
development ar vr maintenance support
design slash graphics and hardware
engineering to work in this sector
at number four we have dark dark is an
emerging technology that several major
industries have their sights on
dark is a combination of distributed
ledger technology
artificial intelligence extended reality
and quantum computing
accenture who introduced dark beliefs
that these technologies combined could
have an enormous impact
on technology as a whole dark is now
primarily geared towards the healthcare
industry
where it is expected to lower the cost
of care improve labor productivity
and enable better experiences for
consumers and partners
due to its currently developing nature
only a few organizations have started
taking advantage of this technology
to get into dark you'll need skills
related to each of its contributing
technologies like dlt
ai xr and quantum computing next up at
number three
as a service cloud services are expected
to provide even more services that make
technology like ai and robotics
accessible to every business
thanks to companies like google
microsoft amazon
a number of startups and innovators
cutting edge technology is accessible to
everyone with little investment
serverless computing is also something
that's being focused on as it provides
users the opportunity to work on the
core product without operating and
managing the servers
hybrid cloud is also expected to show
great growth thanks to its speed
ease of control and security options the
global iaas
paas and saas market size is supposed to
grow to 81 billion dollars
72 billion dollars and 140.6 billion us
dollars respectively to get into cloud
computing you'll need to have an
understanding of the concepts like
different cloud computing platforms
programming languages specialize in
services belonging to compute
storage database domains and so on now
let's talk about number two
automation with an increasing number of
potential cases
initiatives towards self-driving
vehicles would be a priority for civic
authorities and many other organizations
across the world
this ensures that the cost of human
labor is reduced and handles customer
demand there would also be an increase
in the incorporation of robots in the
care and assisted living sectors
robotic devices are also expected to
provide companionship to elderly people
drones are also expected to be
incorporated for delivery of medicine
groceries and other essential goods some
of the popular companies in the field of
automation are siemens
honeywell abb and mitsubishi to get into
automation you will need skills like
programming skills and scripting skills
configuration management software an
understanding of testing tools and so on
and finally at number one artificial
intelligence
ai is a field that's expected to see the
most amount of growth in the next year
ai can help interpret and understand the
enormous amount of content produced
machine learning algorithms would become
better informed and perform much more
sophisticated operations
it is expected to be used to analyze
interactions to determine underlying
connections and insights
to help predict demand for services like
hospitals
and enable authorities to make better
decisions about resource utilization
ai will be used by businesses to detect
the changing patterns of customer
behavior
and for detecting the various ways they
can't be satisfied global spending on
cognitive and ai systems is expected to
reach 57.6 billion dollars by 2021.
and to get into ai you'll need skills
like programming languages
linear algebra probability big data
machine learning algorithms etc on that
note why don't you check out
simplylearn's postgraduate program on ai
and machine learning created in
partnership with purdue university and
in collaboration with ibm
we'll cover a number of topics and
concepts like statistics
python machine learning deep learning
networks
nlp reinforcement learning and much more
to help you grow in
your career and there you go guys that's
our top five
technologies to learn in 2021 with that
we've reached the end of this video
do you think there's something even more
amazing than a.i let us know in the
comment section below
thank you for watching the video and
stay tuned for more from simply learn